there's a chance that you're trying way
too hard to change your life you're
expending all of your willpower on
things that don't require it let me give
you an example I've been playing hockey
for about 20 years so after 20 years of
conditioning what do you think happens
to me when I step inside a hockey rink I
immediately want to play hockey the
environment and the smells and
everything about being inside a hockey
rink creates a downhill slope that makes
me just want to play hockey but little
do we realize everything in our life is
like this especially the spaces that we
most commonly occupy even the smallest
things like the layout of our furniture
what foods are on display in our kitchen
every room in your house is telling you
to live your life in a certain way and a
lot of the time those ways are ways you
want nothing to do with and then when we
try to live our life differently it just
feels like we're swimming Upstream all
the time we can't figure out why nothing
ever sticks